50 kg 50 kg c'est le poids de cet homme
il ya quelques années aujourd'hui il est
champion du monde de bodybuilding
50 kg l'humiliation au quotidien pour ce
jeune beur écrasé dans cette banlieue
lyonnaise mais quand ses copains
enflammé la cité des minguettes à
vénissieux
mohamed benaïssa momo pour tout le monde
commençait à transformer son corps
vingt tonnes de fonte soulevé chaque
jour à l'arrivée il se découvre une
nouvelle confiance en lui
j'ai essayé de pallier ce le fait d'être
algérien pour la bonne et simple raison
c'est qu'on avait toujours cette image
ce jeune délinquant est tout bon le fait
d'être sportif de très haut niveau les
gens quand ils me voyais qu'ils me
connaissent qui m'ont vu dans les
journaux passent à la télé sur les
revues et tous disent tiens mon benaziza
j'ai déjà plus la même étiquette que le
jeune sa jeune notoriété lui a permis de
changer de cadre de vie
c'est à vénissieux où il vit toujours
qu'avec l'aide de sa femme soraya il
adopter une hygiène de vie très stricte
une alimentation rigoureuse composé
uniquement de légumes à la vapeur et de
féculents
mais pour se façonner un corps comme le
sien désormais c'est insuffisant
la prise d'anabolisants valse fait de
partout il faut pas se leurrer mais
disons qu'il faut que ça soit pris
consciemment par l'athlète et
intelligemment qui est un suivi médical
derrière
et où on a toujours en cours à sam à des
doses très réduite puisque les gens ils
ont l'impression que la quantité fait la
performance n'est pas vrai c'est la
qualité que j'aime beaucoup mais disons
que j'irais pas jouer ma santé pour cela
pour l'instant c'est avec du potassium
avaler avec de l'eau déminéralisée la
même que pour les batteries de voitures
ou les fers à repasser que moment
peaufine sa préparation pour son
prochain concours et juste avant de
partir il se remémore une de ses
dernières exhibition % john s on est
encore professionnel la chaîne pour ces
volontaires pendant que ces gros pour
fessenheim
c'est à dire je me suis bien battu
rimini
c'est ici sur les bords de l'adriatique
que les 25 plus et une curiste du monde
vont s'affronter pour le titre suprême
et monsieur la viande soit avec ses
adversaires d'un soir pour la plupart
américains soit un moment d'apprendre le
public une 200 pick up
d'abord une exhibitionniste c'est
surtout dans le regard des autres que
momo entretient sa motivation
on est venu jusqu'ici france pour les
boire pour voir vos mots pour voir ben
photo ciron alors pour une fois qu'on
peut avoir une photo et les approcher et
ben c'est pierre stahl gens continuent
pas je préfère les bistrots et une dune
parlant bien que lorsqu'ils passent
devant moi me disant ok
en un mot si est seul et prétentieux et
où on sait les choses que j'en appelle à
entendre
je ne sors pas je ne bois pas je ne fume
pas ma famille je serai un peu sacrifié
chéroy très peu souvent j'aime ici
pratiquement un salaire par mois dans ma
préparation et tout je pense que ça fait
beaucoup
[Musique]
confiné dans sa chambre d'hôtel à
quelques heures du concours
momo termine sa préparation une
préparation essentiellement esthétiques
afin de valoriser cette masse musculaire
résultat de neuf années d'efforts
ininterrompus déjà arrêté bon ses droits
dès la tête sont toujours sincère bon
construit mon corps qui dit qu'on soit
encore dit se regarder de bazens au
droit gauche
c'est sûr que c'est un peu narcissique
mais c'est le sporting pour momo c'est
maintenant l'ultime répétition avant de
faire exploser ses pectoraux à la face
du monde ce soir il aura trois minutes
de griserie trois minutes pour aller au
bout de ses ambitions
c'est le rêve de tout athlète body
builder de faire au moins dans sa vie
elles ont à faire mono la bombe titre
est une revue spécialisée
et c'est vrai que du haut de ses 1 m 58
il est venu chatouiller les monstres
sacrés du bodybuilding ben aziza
[Applaudissements]
cinquième au monde ce résultat va
au-delà de toutes ses espérances pour
mon cadeau d'anniversaire pour cela
savoir qu'aujourd'hui si je fête mes 30
ans 2
l'anniversaire quelques branches mini 5
mm sur la cas où de deux ans de
professionnalisme pour moi c'est c'est
tout un rêve épuisé physiquement et avec
pour seul spectateur ses copains
d'ateliers il ya parfois des lendemains
qui déchantent 9000 dollars de gains le
prix de sa cinquième place
ce n'est pas encore demain que momo
changera d'horizon on y pense tous à une
carrière d'ardoisé naguère mais faut
savoir carlos 7 à 8 et 15,8 bon ça segal
pas mais c'est sûr que mon but c'est
d'aller m'installer dans le midi et
d'ouvrir salle de musculation pour
l'instant je suis à cheval
[Musique]